hi there steve kaufman here today and i
want to talk about frustrations in
language learning at different stages of
language learning and some of the things
that i do
to
work my way around these frustrations
um i am going to be first of all if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe uh
tomorrow i leave for montreal i'm gonna
spend a week there the city where i grow
up i grew up and i'm going to be taking
part in the long fest the montreal
language festival
uh we're gonna have the participants
from all over north america from all
over the world in fact
and i'm really looking forward
uh ollie richards who was interacting
with me here on my youtube channel
pointed out how difficult it is to learn
vocabulary in asian languages this is
true
i remember from japanese for example you
know at first and this is true of most
languages everything sounds the same
wakarimasu kawarimasu which is two
different things
but in time things become clearer but
there is ongoing frustration as we
continue to not understand forget and
the frustrations or the kinds of things
that frustrate us can be different at
different levels in our learning
now i'm now learning hebrew
i've kind of put greek on the back
burner but i want to get back to my
greek
and
so i'm at the very beginning stages i
have forgotten the frustrations that i
went through with japanese or even with
greek uh four or five months ago i'm
very much aware of the frustrations that
i have in hebrew it's difficult to read
the
vowel uh typically
vowels vowels are not indicated and even
in the when they do show the vowels they
have these microscopic little dots so
hard to see
and i don't really use them very much i
prefer on
link to rely on the voice the text to
speech that pronounces these words for
me but i'm continuing to find it
difficult and i've read a number of
stories many many times listen to them
many many times and continue not to
understand i do understand when i read
the story and i can look up the words
that i've forgotten
but then when i go to listen afterwards
the stories are all some stories 60 some
stories 20
so it is frustrating but i know that i
have to continue to expose myself to
this content because in time it'll
become clearer
uh because the writing system in hebrews
is not consistent in the sense that say
spanish is even in greek you have you
know a number of sounds that can be
represented by several
uh
combinations of of letters
but when you read it
i mean it is more consistent than hebrew
hebrew is is uh
it's it's very let me just let me just
say that it's worse than english so that
is a a level of frustration
but i know i have to continue to expose
my brain to this so
rather than and i have mentioned before
that if you do the same task over and
over again
uh comes a point when the the benefits
the return on investment of time
becomes less and less and less so you
have to vary either you have to vary the
content you're dealing with or you have
to vary the activity so
um i
want to stay with these i have 30 mini
stories in hebrew i want to stay with
these stories i want to try to get to
where i can understand these stories but
by listening to them over and over again
the brain is now saying stop tilt i've
heard them very often i don't understand
them leave me alone so what i do and
what i started doing more and more now
is using tagging
as a mechanical activity i don't like
uh quizzes you know match the hebrew
word with the english word i don't i
don't want to do that i just that's just
the way i'm
i'm made i don't want to do that i i
would rather passively expose myself to
the content but in different ways so i
tagged i began by tagging
whether you know for verb adjective
adverb preposition
because it wasn't obvious to me which
was a verb and which was a preposition
and which was a noun and so forth i
don't tag nouns because there's so many
nouns
so i tagged
those and then i was able to review
those in our what we call activities at
link now at length there is the flash
card there was the multiple choice
there's a fill in the blank closed test
there's dictation and there's what we
call a reverse flash card where you have
the word in english and you have to come
up with the meaning in the target
language well i just use the two easiest
in other words flash cards and multiple
choice
because first of all when the flash card
pops up you hear the text-to-speech
which i like
and i don't spend a lot of time trying
to remember it but most the time i can
remember i know what it means when i see
it when i hear it so that is another way
of reviewing these words even though
when i later on hear them in the context
of a story i forget them
but by tagging them as verbs now i know
that what i'm looking at here you know
when i review them i review 10 or 15
verbs or 10 or 15 adjectives
and that has helped a little bit to sort
of call it deconstruct the language
then i've now refined my approach
somewhat and i tag
and not just for verbs wherever i have
tagged verb i go in and i tag i have
created tags for
think so anything that has to do with a
thought
i can remember different
verbs of thought or might be different
forms of the verb saying thought i call
that think anything that has to do with
i intend to i'm going to i plan to
that's called plan
uh feel is another tag i use for afraid
bored i can't remember them all but
pretty soon
uh i collect
or for food or anything having to do
with learn
because there's you know teach learn
class school
this kind of stuff so i collect
things and i'm experimenting and i think
it's important to experiment and find
out which tags are most useful but i
find it very helpful to go through 10 or
15
of these items vocabulary items uh in
these two activities which is the flash
card where i hear it text to speech and
then again the multiple choice where
again i hear a text-to-speech so i'm
being exposed to it but the advantage is
that it's a mechanical
learning activity i go through the
lesson that i read three four five ten
times and i now go through and i
determine
you know what is the role or function of
this word and i give it
a tag that in itself is already helpful
and it's somewhat mechanical and then i
go to our activities section in the
vocabulary section that link and i go
through 15 or 20 of these
uh
motion for example is one
you know go come leave enter any of
those words that's under motion
uh anything having to do give take by
that sort of action of grabbing taking
giving that's another i call that take
you can give it your own definition and
some of these tags work better than
others and you can change as you go
along
uh
but it gives you another way of exposing
yourself
and and sort of focusing on a certain
type of word
and i find that when i go back and read
and listen i understand better now as
you progress in the language you'll find
different things challenging uh i should
say first of all that having spent now
two weeks on hebrew when i go back to
greek i find greek very easy
so one advantage of pushing yourself and
something more difficult is when you go
back to something that you're more
familiar with it all of a sudden seems a
lot easier than it was before
plus i've listened to the greek stories
many many more times
and as i say the writing system is not
as strange to me as the hebrew writing
system
but in slavic languages of course i tag
for
cases
in other words this is the instrumental
case or the genitive case or i tag for
you know verbs emotion aspect of verbs
these kinds of grammatical structural
things that cause me trouble and in
slavic languages i tag phrases because
i'm more advanced
so
i may eventually want to
with the slavic languages
also instead of just doing the simple
flashcards in multiple choice i might do
the reverse flashcard where i have to
translate from the english into
polish ukrainian or whatever it might be
so by varying what it is you choose to
save and tag word or phrase
sentence even
and which activities you're going to use
you can continue to vary this sort of
call it mechanical activity so it is
another way that you can advance your
learning
doing something that's
somewhat mechanical as a relief from
continuing to
uh struggle against you know
particularly in the early stages this
fact that you keep forgetting your feet
you keep not understanding
uh i find that in the languages where
i'm more advanced
i don't really need to tag for
vocabulary because i understand it so
well
that i know with time that things are
going to fall into place the words are
going to start to stick but that there
are certain structural patterns that my
brain is just not yet
used to and so i tend to focus in on
those areas it might be subjunctive in
spanish or whatever it might be so just
a bit of advice that you can use this
tool of tagging and experiment with it
as a means of overcoming the kinds of
frustrations that we inevitably come
across in language learning so i hope
this was
helpful
i look forward to seeing any of you that
are going to be in montreal
in this coming week
and thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you